hey guys what's up its Daniel in here
from DLM model lifestyle now a lot of
you have asked how do I know that I can
be a model so today I'm here in Cape
Town South Africa with contact models and I'm
here with my boss I'm working with Gavin
here in Cape Town and I asked him if he
can explain to you guys how do you know
how you can be a model
alright so Gavin okay so finding a model
is it's quite a tricky thing because we
get to see a lot of people on a daily
basis everybody messages us saying I
want to be a model so there's a couple
of things to keep in mind particularly
for a male model and these are kind of
international requirements you need to
be of a certain height now it's not
exactly kind of like science in terms of
kind of you know very very specific
there is a leeway depending on your
character and your mood or whatever but
you need to be a certain height and I
would say around about 6 foot is kind of
like a good sweet spot anything short than that
becomes a little bit of a problem if you are
shorter than that it's not a massive
train smash yeah a couple of centimeters
shorter because we're always looking for
people who are interesting do you have
tattoos do you have
particular kind of look about you a look
or a feel that we can sell to clients a
very unique look correct if you have a unique look it
kind of makes life a little bit easier
and then you get a little bit of of lea
way also there's commercial models and
editorial models when we say editorial
we're thinking generally a magazine so
is it a guy that could be in the pages
of a magazine or is it a commercial
model so is it a guy that is that the
dad in a yoghurt
commercial or in insurance commercial so
there's various aspects of modeling but
ultimately it's about selling yourself
so can you walk into a room and sell
yourself does the client want you to be
the name and face of that product whatever
the product may be so it's about the
look it's about selling yourself and
it's about being professional a lot of
people don't realize about modelling is that it is a job and if you're a
secretary or a doctor or a lawyer you
show up on time you make your
appointments your act in a professional
way and being a model has the same
requirement so it's about how you
look but also how you conduct
yourself because it's easy to say I'm a
male model but am i working male model
that's where the difference is so yes
your look and your height and your size
but also how professional are you and
that's what can make you a successful
model all right so for girls if they're
around sixteen years old and they want to
start modeling what is the the sizes and
the length that they need to be okay so
particularly for young girls to start
modelling I would say the first step is to
do your homework and your research about
the agency so there's a lot of people
who are managers and promoters and
people who are trying to get young girls
and represent them and manage them
but you know it is really
important to be careful about who you
associate with in this business so
particularly young girls do your
research before you join an agency
commit to the manager
sign anything and know what you're
getting into then the next thing is your
sizes I would say at 16 you need to be a
minimum height of 174 and hopefully you will grow
a little bit ideally you need to be like
178 age right about there that's like
the sweet spot that you want at an
international career yeah fashion a 90
hip is ideal but again there's a lot of
kind of leeway in terms of like
commercial modeling and that kind of
stuff there is definitely a trend you know
it used to be about the girls
being super super thin now it's about being super fit and toned
so there is that market you're
that very high fashion very thin
girl yeah but it seems to be less & less
a client wants to see a strong
firm body as opposed to a very thin body
but yeah and I think that is definitely
become a very big distinction and a lot
of young girls don't see that at
beginning they starve themselves they
eat unhealthy and it catches up to them so I
would say that to be a successful model
is not about being the thinnest it's
just about being as toned and the best
version of yourself rather than being
super super skinny so looking really
healthy correct thats correct
a healthy lifestyle that's what clients want they
don't want a girl in their commercial
that looks ill and malnourished or under
fed so it's about really looking after
yourself particularly at that age we see a
lot of girls coming in and their
perception is that models don't eat
models don't do this, they workout three
times a day that's not necessarily true
modelling is grueling especially for
girls because there's a lot of work
there's a lot of travel you need to be
physically and mentally fit to be a
successful model there's no point starving
yourself and being unhealthy and being
sick on set we need a healthy
strong model and that's what makes you
successful all right and for for girls
and guys until what age can they do modelling
well that also changed a lot in the
last couple of years um you know 20
years ago when you've kind of hit 25
your career was actually over, over, over
which is a bit frightening but nowadays
clients have kind of realized that if you're selling
a product particularly an expensive
products so a Rolex a Landrover a
expensive eye cream the kind of person
that's buying that product is not 25 they are
45 so there is a lot of marketing using
older models so it can be more relatable
to the market and to the kind of client
that they're trying to pick up
which is great so the thing is
when you get older it's not so
passionate anymore but in terms of like
money
and the kind of clients there are those
clients who want an older model yeah
the oldest model I've represented is at
that point he was in his 70's and he did
really really well so your never too
young or too old but just realize that
the kind of client base as you get older
changes and generally they have more money
which is good because ultimately it's a
business and that's what your here for so
any age is good alright guys now you
have a lot of information now you know
if you can become a model I just want to
thank Gavin here he's very very busy
always happy to help
he's on the phone all day to get more
jobs so if you have any questions just
ask it in the comments below if you did
not subscribe yet please do and I'll see
you in the next video